bonjour au peuple d internet et
bienvenue dans cette sixième
jean-françois cette version dans cette
sixième vidéo du 6 décembre de ce mental
vlog masse calendrier de l'avent youtube
aujourd'hui bien un livre que j'aime
particulièrement
et on va parler de ce livre parce qu'il
ya des trucs vraiment intéressant et
drôle dedans je les range est
précieusement dans cette petite mallette
presque magique mais quand on faisait
tel pour rentrer dedans c'est beaucoup
trop bon c'est des effets spéciaux de
malade je vous ai nuque et les oreilles
parce que micro est là et ça fait aussi
plaisir
avant de parler du livre en lui-même est
de vous rappeler que c'est pas un
placement produit je vous je vous
recommande également les deux anciens
hits de la même collection sont 50 imac
dot 50 drôle d'anecdote scientifique
pour calmer un peu les pubs plus 12 et
50 drôle d'anecdote historique pour se
la raconter dans les dîners et ses
bouquins j'en avais déjà parlé un petit
peu sur la chaîne ils viennent de sortir
un troisième tome ça fait cinquante
drôle d'anecdote savante pour estomaqué
ce qui la ramène trop tabusse étrange
quand je parle près de l'allant pour
montant vachement mieux c'est quand même
bizarre qui se passe du rose c'est un
petit peu incroyable alors dans le livre
on a des titres dans le sommaire qui
ressemblerait presque à des vidéos
youtube respirer donne le cancer
l'internet est contrôlé par sept
personnes qui possèdent cette clé le
paradoxe du menteur est faux le kilo se
trouve en france l'a inventé la pire
odeur du monde vraiment le l'auteur fred
royer peut ouvrir une chaîne youtube et
faire exactement ce titre-là en vidéo
gras pas de souci ça marchera mais c'est
vraiment traiter comme ça donc avec un
point de vue scientifique mais de
manière très drôle
je vais vous en lire un particulièrement
qui s'appelle le nombre d'or n'existe
pas et comme à chaque chapitre il ya
deux informations
d'abord acquis le raconter donc là c'est
plutôt à des architectes puisque je vous
rappelle que le fin du titre du livre
c'est pour estomaqué ceux qui se la
raconte trop donc on raconte cette
anecdote à des architectes et l' indice
de geekerie à quel point tu es geek si
tu racontes ça je trouve ça quand même
vraiment très drôle comme approche look
yoga sur tout l'historique du nombre
d'heures
toutes les légendes urbaines ci qui est
un petit peu au tour et vous allez vite
vous rendre compte que la peau
l'occurrence pour ce chapitre là c'est
pour ça que je le lis pas ce que je
dévoile rien ça c'est un canular
il va revenir sur l'approximation du
nombre d'or en fait le nombre d'or
n'existe pas dans l'architecturé au sens
propre du terme c'est pour ça que vous
racontez ça des architectes parce que
c'est un nombre irrationnel et
transcendance dire que après la virgule
ça va jusqu'à l'infini s'est jamais
cycliques et on ne peut donc
matériellement pas reproduire exactement
le nombre d'or on sera toujours sur un
arrondi genre 1,680 alors au lieu de 1,6
8 1 3 ha ha et je crois que les mâles
dis donc quand même je leur dirai que le
nombre d'or c'est un adulte 6 1 8 0 face
à l'arrondi qu'on utilise le plus
souvent et après tumulte roi et c'est à
ce qu'il a derrière si tu as envie mais
du coup les architectes ne peuvent pas
nier que réellement dans leur
architecture le nombre d'or exact
n'existe jamais oui c'est du trot ligne
pour architecte j'aime gagner donc après
autant il est intéressant ce nombre d'or
autant il ya vraiment beaucoup de
légendes urbaines sur les proportions du
corps humain sur certains tableaux sur
certaines architectures qui perdure
encore aujourd'hui et je trouve ça drôle
de pouvoir faire un canular dessus parce
que ça dénonce un petit peu je vous
propose aussi l'un des exercices en fait
une devinette qui propose à la fin ce
sont les 100 premiers nombres naturel
qui est classé dans un ordre précis je
voulais lit et vous devez trouver dans
quel ordre ils sont classés hockey 105
50 55 52 51 58 59 54 57 c'est comme si
53 2
18 19 17 12 8 9 11
on peut s'arrêter là que vous laisse
avec ça dans quel ordre sont classés
nombre et les chiffres que vient de vous
donner vous pouvez donner votre réponse
dans les commentaires et je vous
donnerai la réponse dans la vidéo de
demain
en plus vous mais un lien vers vers vers
tout le bouquin les anciens gones a déjà
parlé et le nouveau si ça vous intéresse
dans la description vous le trouverez
facilement puisqu'il est juste en
dessous du lien pour réserver vos places
pour l'olympia qui pourrait être un
super idée de cadeau de noël aussi
pourquoi pas comme d'habitude vous
pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air vous
abonner à la chaîne
à très bientôt c'est à dire demain matin
à 6 heures du matin merci à vous à toi
et surtout à toi ciao